So many music stars are
paying tribute to Tony Bennett tonight,
including two Grammy Award
winning singers.
Michael Bublé
will join us in just a moment.
But right now,
we are pleased to welcome harry
connick, jr.
Into The Situation Room.
It's an embarrassment of riches
for us here in The Situation Room.
Harry, great to see you.
How are you?
Remembering this icon
and your friend, Tony Bennett.
I mean, we were just looking through
all those clips there.
What an amazing life.
Well, it's good to be with you, Jim.
Thanks for having me.
I was so saddened to hear about it
because I've known Tony for years,
probably since I was a teenager.
I think when he came through New Orleans
was the first time I met him.
And I just remember him
aside from we could talk for hours about
what an unbelievable musical talent
he was.
Yeah,
but he was so nice to me, always so kind.
His arms were always open,
so encouraging.
And I just have a lot of
laugh when I think
about it, because he was the kind of guy
I would love to have him
come on stage and sing with me.
But you also had to be careful
because you knew
who was going to get the most applause
and it wasn't going to be me.
No, I'm sure a lot of singers
felt that way.
But how did Tony Bennett's
unique impact
on pop and jazz inspire you?
Because it was
such a unique and iconic voice.
The good times.
Yeah, his voice was one of a kind.
You know,
he just had this incredible ability
to interpret lyrics
and an unbelievable amount of power
in his voice.
When you couple that with his elegance,
his talking humility
and his incredible ability to
to to bring an audience into
some of the
Great American Songbook, it was
it was one of these once in a lifetime
kind of kind of things.
There was nobody
who really did it like him.
And I don't think there
I can
assure you there will never, ever
be anybody who doesn't like Tony Bennett.
Yeah.
What was it like
being in the room with him?
Were you starstruck yourself at first?
Well, I'll tell you a quick story.
When I was in my mid-twenties,
I was playing a concert.
There were a bunch of singers on the bill
and the way the lineup was,
I was going out to sing
and he was going to follow me,
which was a very good thing
because you don't want
to follow Tony Bennett.
And I sang
I got out there with a microphone,
and I usually hold him
like pretty close to my mouth.
But this time I saw him in the wings
watching me,
and I held the mic about two feet away.
And I was saying in my mind,
I hope he's watching this.
My sound is getting bigger.
Tony Bennett's got a big sound,
but I'm I'm working on my sound.
And so I sang the song.
It was fine and went off stage.
Tonight, Mr.
Bennett says, Oh, hi.
He walks out.
He says, Good evening,
ladies and gentlemen,
and takes the microphone
and puts it down on the piano.
And sang the song without a microphone.
And I'm like,
I just wanted to
I just wanted to crawl into a hole
because, you know, that's why
you don't follow Tony Bennett.
You can't
you know, you just can't win
kind of a mic drop over there.
Well, Harry Connick, Jr. Exactly.
Great to talk to you.
We could go on all night.
Really appreciate you coming in.
The Situation Room.
And my hat's off to you as well.
What an amazing career you've had.
And thanks for sharing
those special memories.
We really appreciate it.
Thank you, Jim.
Good to be with you. Good to be with you.
All right.
Now let's bring in another modern day
crooner and Grammy Award winning artist
Michael Bublé.
He is also with us.
Thanks for joining us.
Michael, great to see you.
And you had the honor of collaborating
with Tony Bennett on several duets.
I have to ask you about that.
What was it like to sing with
such a giant in the industry?
It is tough to
to share a stage with them.
I have to imagine
that while I mean,
he's incredibly talented,
but he was always warm and gracious.
And, you know, as a
as a kid who had so much reverence
for him,
and the heroes that
that come before
me and the Great American Songbook,
you can imagine how much it meant
to have him take a kid
like me under his wing. And
I loved just every time I got
a chance
to be with them, to talk with them,
to ask him questions.
And I remember the first time
I was with him, I was very nervous.
I told the story too many times
but it bears repeating.
I said, Mr.
Bennett, I have stolen everything
from you
and Frank and Dean and Bobby and Al.
And he said to me, kid, he said,
We get steel from one person.
You're a thief.
He said, But if you steal from everybody,
it's research.
And I've told that story so many times,
and I continue to steal from those greats
and from the news.
What a class act.
Absolutely.
And that is an amazing story.
And I think about how
he had such
an amazing stage
presence early on in his career,
right up until the end,
and just had this powerful voice
that was UNMIS stackable.
What was it about Tony Bennett that
connected with you, Joe?
Well, I love that person.
The voice was unique.
The God kiss that man's throat
and everybody knew
the great ones knew it. Frank knew it.
They all knew it.
What I really find
fascinating about it, though,
is now that I got to spend
20 years
watching and being and seeing this guy,
I was always amazed by the fact
it's a great lesson to learn.
By the way, in any business
you're in
know who you are,
be confident in who you are.
And he was.
And even though times change
and tastes change
and your audience goes
and comes and your popularity wanes,
you just if you're really confident
and you really know who you are
and you have that kind of integrity,
they'll find you.
And we always found Tony,
as a matter of fact, coming here today.
A girlfriend of mine was outside
with a message and she said,
Are you okay?
She said, Well, it's a really tough day.
I love Tony Bennett.
She said, I was.
I spent the whole morning
listening to her and she's 24.
She's been four years. She's a kid.
And now,
and now we we pay great respect.
And those of us who are lucky, you know,
people like Harry
Connick, Jr and myself, and Lady Gaga
and Diana Krall,
Jamie Cullum, people that he
he sort of
opened up to and took under their wing.
Now it's our wonderful responsibility
to make sure in our small lives
we keep the legacy of not only Tony, but
I think the greatest gift
America ever gave to the arts.
The great American Songbook.
We keep it going in his name.
What an honor
and a real privilege
to be able to do that.
And you know, what
a remarkable music career
he had spanning more than 70 years,
touching just about every generation
of the last century.
What sort of legacy does
he leave behind, do you think?
I think it's never ending.
I truly do. I think he's truly an icon.
I mean,
he has changed the face of music.
And it's
not just in the beautiful country
of America
or even North America, including cats.
It is worldwide.
I mean, listen,
I toured nearly 50 countries this year,
and there's not a place
there's not a language
spoken that doesn't love him
and that won't love him forever.
He'll become part
of all our lives in wonderful moments
when we get married
or when we fall in love to
the difficult moments,
you know,
when we're saying goodbye to each other.
He's he's
just become a part of culture and
you can imagine
it's a very strange day
for so many of us.
You know, I done Danny this morning,
and we have
we talked and
and I told Danny
just listen
how remarkable it was for me
as a as a father of four kids
to know that his kid loved him
so much and understood the legacy
and was a part of that journey
in keeping this incredible dude
more than relevant
the way he did it
I mean, it is a fascinating tale.
It truly is. It's the movie, which
it just means a lot to me that I can
come on here, Jim, and just sort of share
what it meant for me
to have him in my life.
And I mean, it changed my career, man.
When a guy like that
says to the world, hey,
this is, you know,
this is this guy's okay, that really does
It really does change things for you.
I bet
that's always going to stay with you.
Whether we've had times of great sadness
or great joy in our lives, it seems like
he was part of that soundtrack.
I think that's what's
just going to be so special about him.
We always leaned on Tony
in those moments in our lives.
Mike Man, like you said it.
You said it best.
He that I am the original American Idol.
And he still is.
He really is.
No question about it.
Michael Bublé, honored to have you on.
Thanks so much.
We're all thrilled to have you with us.
Harry Connick, Jr as well.
You're both wonderful.
Thanks so much.
And what a tribute to Tony Bennett.
I'm sure he'd be proud.
All right. We'll be right back.
Who gets too hungry?